here is video of John fetterman who is a
Pennsylvania Senate candidate running
against Dr Oz and uh well just watch
are so much better
than Eagles at first I just wanted to
check in and see how how you're feeling
and how you're doing
I'm doing fine I'm doing fantastic and
and uh it's not about kicking balls in
the Authority or anything and make sure
you take advantage of this amazing
opportunity to the only thing you have
stand to lose is your record what is
wrong with demanding for
an easy
safe
kind of
their income a path to a safe place for
them to win and I can Champion the union
way of life
in Jersey and excuse me in D.C if you
come out
and step with us
we will be able to stand with you in DC
uh that guy is basically neck and neck
with Dr Oz right now now I do want to be
clear about one thing he had a stroke a
couple months ago I am not belittling in
any way the the repercussions of the
stroke this is to illustrate should this
person be running for office we already
know what's going on with Biden there is
something wrong there do we need more of
this on top of the fact that he's always
wearing the hoodie he doesn't come off
as professional at all he also his his
litany if you were just to look at the
list of stuff that he's into this guy
wants to put all the criminals back out
on the streets he wants every every
Equity based nonsense policy of the
progressives is what this guy wants but
for some reason the machine is pushing
him over and over and over and over uh
here's video this is from uh just about
two days ago I think of fetterman
talking about his stroke his campaign
required that he'd be allowed to use a
transcription program on his computer
during our interview I always thought I
was pretty empathetic uh uh emphatic
uh I think I was very excuse me
empathetic uh you know that's an example
of stroke empathetic I always thought I
was very empathetic uh before having a
stroke but now after having that stroke
I really understand you know much more
kind of the challenges that Americans
have
okay so again I am not making fun of
anyone for having a stroke my dad had a
very severe stroke 25 years ago thank
God he's okay
um so that it's not about that is the
point is should this guy with whatever
is going on with him put aside the bad
policies you have all the bad policies
that's just standard Democrat stuff at
this point but should this person be in
the U.S Senate it doesn't really seem
like you should you know what's
interesting about that so he was getting
the transcription on the computer now
the transcription just meant that her
words were being translated so he could
read them so I don't even know what he
was reading as he was all confused there
it's it's a real mess but here once
again you see how the machine protects
certain people with certain points of
views and the Machine is protecting him
just because they don't want Dr Oz at Dr
Oz by the way is no like standard bearer
of republicanism I mean he's sort of a
lukewarm moderate I think the guy's
pretty decent actually uh but like it's
not like he's some you can't say that's
a crazy Maga far-right Republican but
the machine obviously wants veteran more
than him so they will do everything they
can to sort of make you not see what
what you can see right in front of your
eyes